american people are well positioned to
face these challenges because of the
economic historic
gains that we have made
under this president under this
president in the last 16 months the
white house spinning like there's no
tomorrow on the economy and actually
claiming it's a historic success
the economy is historic under biden but
for all the wrong reasons the stock
market plunging into a bear market and
killing your retirement accounts gas
prices almost hitting 10 bucks a gallon
in some places after joe said he wanted
to end fossil fuels and inflation's
crushing the american people costing
them thousands of dollars more per year
the endless stream of bad news not
stopping joe biden from hitting the road
though to bash republicans and boast
about his so-called successes
20 million americans had lost their jobs
on last sky
in fact so many americans lost their
jobs that my predecessor became just the
second president in history to leave
office with fewer jobs in america than
when he took office remember those long
lines of cars stretching miles back
waiting for just a box of food to be put
back in their trunk
wasn't just poor folk
it was working class what was middle
class folks
a lot of pretty nice cars in those lines
i don't want to hear any more of these
lies
about reckless spending
we're changing people's lives
the problem is republicans in congress
are doing everything they can
to stop my plans to bring down costs on
ordinary families i believe in
bipartisanship but i have no illusions
about this republican party the maga
party they seem to think that the
problem in america today as the working
families aren't paying enough
you know what i didn't hear dana i
didn't hear a lot of clapping
oh you know what but that was edited out
yeah yeah yeah of course yeah what do
you think i don't know i i i was sitting
here thinking i'm listening i'm thinking
i would just rip up the whole plan
their whole communications plan rip it
up but it's again as i said last night
on exclamation point it's not a
communications problem they have a
policy problem but they will not admit
it and it's the strangest thing i've
ever seen you know they careen between
everything is great or we can't do
anything about it right and you even
have all of this throwing in of the
towel by the cabinet like you know
there's not much yeah we got nothing for
you on that nope not not here either um
that's like a collective throwing in of
the towel that is
just a slap in the face to the american
people and i'm you know i try to find a
silver lining i try to find a hopeful
spot they're just not giving you one
it's almost as if they think if we just
keep talking about it everything is
going to change and you can't do that
you have to play against type what would
happen if they were to all of a sudden
just rip everything up take a step back
and
think for a second
about what they are saying what they are
doing because right now it's just like
pounding a square peg into a round hole
and it does not fit and it will not
change anything and i feel bad for
people i feel bad for that because it's
real when you when you go to the gas
station and you think well
if i put two gallons in i can afford to
get to work today but this keeps going
and people are i know a guy in tennessee
oh i don't know i read about him he gave
an interview to the paper he quit his
job
because it cost him more to
fuel up to go to work than he made in a
day that's sad and it's it's really sad
and i just feel like that you know he's
supposed to be mr empathy and it's not
coming through yeah so the central
argument as dana points out everything
is great it's all putin's fault and i
can't do anything about it makes no
logical sense and everything he had said
there was
would
you could buy if you had absolutely no
memory
of what happened which was covid there
was an upheaval people were waiting in
line for this the fact that he made it
about trump is pretty amazing when you
look at that video there's only one
conclusion you can come to in that he's
he's not
right he's not well
uh he'd be a terrific president if
things were fine and you had all the
basics covered but this is not that time
this is not the right person for a
crisis if you have a strong economy and
you have you know you have peace and
prosperity you can you can have a
back-slabbing boob
like him but right now i mean this is
this is kind of scary when you see that
in the fact that he feels the need to
yell
louder and louder as if that's a point
and it make and i think that that comes
to what you're saying i don't think he's
capable of thinking his way through
these things anymore i think it's you
know you could easily predict this
disaster when he got elected i mean
who's better at economic issues
republicans who's not welcome for input
republicans so all you get is one half
of the equation and one half of that
equation isn't even there it's basically
a zero and so what do you do when you
multiply something by zero hold on i
know this
you get a zero
you get a zero you went to prayer he
only cares about himself now he's only
okay it's like if it doesn't affect him
as a politician as a leader as a person
at home it doesn't matter it doesn't
exist it's kind of frightening in a way
yeah he's totally lost geraldo
he said a lot of things that just flat
out were false uh would you like to
well say anything about all the
falsehoods there there are uh indeed
some things that uh that strain
credulity but i find it ironic that greg
for instance prefers
uh trump to biden when you look at
president trump in the light of these
january 6th hearings
and you see how absolutely crazy he
became after the election and how close
uh he came to impeding and uh you know
destroying the transition of peaceful
transition of power for the first time
in american history what does it have to
do with biden what it has to do is you
can't
biden is a old
fellow who's got some fragility and he's
got communication problems and he may i
don't know
if he's as sharp as he as he always was
but if the alternative
is the his predecessor we have to
recognize and remember i love donald
trump oh please
please i went please i i felt
very close to him i've known him 40
years 40 years and then you turn the
knife and
and what he did he turned the knife in
america's back it was him that turned
the knife and that it is becoming clear
now
that republicans are in a kind of denial
it is not shocking
how many people
support
donald trump what is shocking is how
many people support donald trump who
also believe that he did everything he
is accused of doing by the day so why do
they call it january 6th it was one day
we're talking about an administration
trump was trump was president for four
years we had a great economy we had
peace we oh my god his personality upset
you the man you love so much geraldo and
now it just pains you that was one day
all right you can't compare the two and
by the way no lie as far as i know what
are the conclusions you're just basing
this on an emotional response are they
saying he did anything wrong i didn't
expect to talk about this
he
uh he was absolutely the driving force
for
what was the most uh traumatic in
european event to the american democracy
i don't know how can you talk
you cut me off i was going to put it in
perspective oh i'm sorry for that
perspective i'm not sorry for cutting
you off for all though let's go to judge
jeanine yeah let's stay to the top
the topic is the delusional guy who is
actually talking about the economic
historic gains that we have in this
country this man is delusional i'm
telling you he is delusional you can't
pretend there's a historic boom
when the truth is people can't afford to
pay for their gas they can't afford to
eat and the baby formula in this country
is under lock and key we're living like
a third world country when you see the
shelves in the grocery stores and it's
just starting this food shortage it's
coming folks it's going to get worse
because of fuel and because of
fertilizer now in the usa we've got the
fastest growing economy let me tell you
something that's a lie i looked up
countries with faster growing economies
in the united states and i'm taking my
time because you talked about
what about trump let me tell you who's
better better
okay ireland is doing better than us
chile turkey colombia drug dealing
colombia india greece
china of course is doing better the
united kingdom france italy panama the
dominican republic guyana and i could go
on and these fools are talking about the
historic economic boom that's going on
in this country they're lying to you and
let me make it even clearer every month
you're paying a tax in the amount of 400
through this inflation and because of
his insistence on green energy because
joe biden insisted on shutting down
fossil fuels and making us independent
now he's going on his knees to opec to
beg for oil and the cost of diesel is so
much it's actually curtailing heavy
equipment use reducing the number of
hours that farm tractors can work so how
about that build back better folks when
the bulldozers and the tractors can't
run anymore the biden administration is
engaging in economic euthanasia
that's what we're suffering from in this
country they are killing americans every
month with their economic policies and
we are losing to panama did you say yes
unacceptable we need to step it up we
definitely need to i will not lose to
panama
that means we have to legalize drugs
yeah all right greg
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now